[Musique]
ce n'est pas par hasard si nous
démarrons par celle là vous savez
aurélien le disais à l'instant dans le
petit film de présentation
c'est un français sur trois qui est
concerné c'est 11 millions d'aidants qui
qu'on ne se préoccupe pas de ce sujet et
qu'on ne le portent pas quelle doit être
la place que nous réservons personnes
porteuses d'un handicap comment nous
favorisons l'insertion dans le milieu
ordinaire
comment effectivement nous allons
améliorer la situation de façon à ce que
chacun d'entre nous est bien puisse se
révéler au sein de notre république
c'est ça l'adn de la droite républicaine
valeurs de solidarité et républicains
depuis plusieurs moins cherche à se
mettre à la hauteur des français à ne
pas être au dessus des français 22
millions de nos concitoyens sont de
prêts concernés par le handicap
cette vision là que nous allons
développer ce soir au travers d'une
série de témoignages une série de
discussions des changes et de
propositions c'est une vision de la
politique et de la république bien nous
sommes très fiers aussi au sein du
groupe et l'air au sénat d'être à
l'origine du groupe handicap qui a été
créée il ya cinq ans et puis vous dire
également que
notre nouveau politique également
présent au sein du cncph conseil
national consultatif des personnes
handicapées et donc nous portons
également notre voix et nos convictions
au sein de cette instance importante
non donc il est véritablement urgent que
l'état montre l'exemple donc l'éducation
nationale de vars côté comme le disait
un instant trente mille personnes en
situation de handicap et donc remplacer
un départ à la retraite sur six par une
personne en situation de handicap pour
le statut de ces aidants il faut
absolument le reconnaître est aussi
dénoncée qu'il ya un manque d'ambition
de la part du gouvernement sur ce sujet
nous maintiendrons aussi et ça c'est
important parce qu'on se demande un peu
dans le flou et le texte sur les
retraites c'est les huit trimestres
réputé cotiser pour les parents
d'enfants en situation de handicap
et puis nous assurons aussi le droit à
des formations pour les parents qu'il
demande dont les enfants sont en
situation de handicap faut aussi bien
sûr que les professeurs des écoles que
les professeurs de collèges soit
également formés à l'accueil on ne peut
pas leur reprocher aujourd'hui de ne pas
savoir faire parce que dans la formation
aujourd'hui d'émettre par la forme et à
la formation des professeurs peu de
chose est prévue j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec aurélien durant
plusieurs mois pour préparer cette
convention et je vois que c'est
l'aboutissement avec dix mesures très
très forte qui va redonner encore plus
de sens à l'handicap mais sont aussi de
l'aide et essayer de changer le regard
parce que c'est vraiment ce qu'on doit
faire changer le regard sur le handicap
alors effectivement dans les dix
propositions peut retenir statut des
aidants la question de l'âge qui sont
remontés quotidiennement par les
associations est ce que je retiens moi
c'est un pragmatisme
une écoute du terrain avec des
témoignages qui correspondait
complètement aussi aux réalités et
vraiment on voit des républicains sur ce
sujet qui est majeur sont au point et
continue dans la tradition de la droite
républicaine apporte des sujets des
envies ce qui m'a beaucoup intéressé
frappé aussi dans cette convention c'est
qu'on a abordé la question du handicap
psychique qui est trop souvent oubliée
et peu mis en avant
et là on a eu un témoignage de la femme
et des propositions concrètes pour un
sujet qui est trop souvent oubliée qui
est fondamental excellent convention sur
un thème en ce qui me concerne moi qui
m'est particulièrement cher c'est tout
ce qui tourne autour de l'autisme et du
traitement des jeunes la détection de
l'autisme chez les plus jeunes
pratiquement dans les premiers mois de
l'année après la naissance et surtout le
traitement des jeunes adultes après
qu'ils aient été traités à l'heure pile
était encore mineure et qui deviennent
une charge très lourde pour leurs
parents là il ya vraiment un travail à
faire de même qu'il faudra bien
évidemment se préoccuper de la formation
des aidants sur cette question d'
autisme parce que il y a beaucoup à
faire à ce niveau là je suis venu au
temps du vestiaire parce que toute ma
vie j'ai dit cause que vous confronter à
l'handicap est particulièrement
l'handicap psychiatrique et nous avons
beau très peu un moyen pour permettre
aux malades de se réinsérer dans la vie
active
automatiquement sa retraite des rechutes
fréquentes et s'il y avait les moyens de
pouvoir les remettre au travail devra
parler dans le gotha puis plus active et
qu'il est parachuté dans une vie active
je suis sûr qu'on pouvait gagner 30 à 40
% d'amélioration
écoutez je suis vraiment très heureux de
voir que les républicains reprendraient
une thématique qui nous concerne tous au
quotidien de voir que c'est enfin un
sujet d'intérêt général que qui est
repris par par les républicains on sent
aujourd'hui que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse pas beaucoup les politiques
malgré toutes les difficultés que
peuvent rencontrer à la fois les
familles à la fois les personnes
handicapées et de pouvoir travailler sur
un grand nombre de propositions dix
propositions étaient donnés ce soir pour
aider les personnes handicapées aider
les aidants et puis retrouver le courage
aussi de réaffirmer débat des
propositions politiques dans notre
société me paraît aussi primordial élu
départemental avec une aussi avec une
mdph et bien nous avons besoin aussi
nous département nous améliorer dans les
réponses faites aux personnes
handicapées aujourd'hui on a besoin de
mieux évaluer leur situation n'a besoin
de mieux les accompagner et je pense que
c'est un travail qu'on peut faire aussi
sur le plan national donc bravo aux
républicains et bravo à tous ceux qui
ont travaillé sur sur cette convention
pour améliorer les conditions et des
personnes handicapées en france